a normal distribution so far all we've
been doing is looking at the numbers of
it right like this percentage that's
called all the rest but so far through
this topic we've actually been dealing
with like calculus and stuff right
you're like we're on the calculus gone
right well we haven't been able to deal
with anything calculus because when it
comes to this shape we haven't had
anything to integrate we haven't had the
actual function that you can put into an
integral putting boundaries in all the
rest right so that's what I'm gonna
unpack for you right now and it's
dealing with this function is what's
gonna be tomorrow and Friday's lesson
okay so remember what the probability
density function is this is all stuff
from that piece of paper that I gave you
good day right these are the three
qualities that the probability density
function has and what we're going to try
and do is almost like guess who like
we're going to try and work out what's
the function that makes sense of all of
this that has all of these
characteristics right now we have lots
of different functions though these are
all the functions that you learnt about
in graphing techniques plus a little bit
more actually like you can graph with
some help even if you're not very
familiar you can graph all of these okay
so what you have to think about which of
these would be closest to something like
the probability density function shape
that we've been dealing with the normal
distribution okay now there's a lot to
play with you so I'm gonna try and
narrow it down for you okay
you remember have said this is kind of
like guess who okay you know how there
are some questions that you should ask
early on like is the person male/female
or do they wear glasses or have they got
hair right so there are obvious
questions to ask the most obvious
question out of these three to look at
is this guy right here you know how its
on the levels off and then it's got
asymptotes horizontally right I want you
to think about these six families of
functions and which of them have
horizontal asymptotes versus which that
don't have a think okay so maybe some of
you think okay which one's doing which
ones don't do you agree with me they can
we can really quickly say all of these
guys they're all duds do you see that
polynomials are like straight lines
parabolas they don't have horizontal
asymptotes in fact they don't have
asymptotes at all absolute values are
the same
dogs do you have asymptotes but not
horizontal ones they have vertical ones
okay
trig functions I mean you've got sine
and cos then in about some totes tans
got asymptotes but which way do they go
that you're up and down so they're also
yeah they're vertical okay so that
leaves us with these two rational
functions like something divided by
something and then Exponential's and I
think with me maybe it's been a while
since you've had a look at it do you
remember like rational functions they
look like this Summa yeah the hyperbola
very weird our old friend okay now the
problem with every rational function is
not only do they have the horizontal
asymptotes we want but have a look at it
it's also got vertical ones and this has
no vertical asymptotes do you see that
okay so all that lays you with is the
exponential function this is the only
one we can work with except just look at
it for a second right it doesn't look
anything like this does it right well
ah no good right so part of it does but
part of it doesn't like you've got this
part over here which has that horizontal
asymptote behavior that's the part we
want right and then you have this
right-hand side you're like that's
that's no good right I don't want the
right-hand side to do that skyrocket
anything that makes sense okay so how do
I fix this well have a look at the
x-values that work for us
do you agree if the good x-values are
the negatives ones right the negative
x-values they could the positive ones no
good what knowledge do we have what
concept do we have that can fix numbers
so that they're always positive or
negative what we call that we call
absolute value right now normally we
would say you put the absolute value
signs around it and what does that mean
absolute value means always positive
but I don't want the positive side I
want the I want the negative side so
here's what I'm going to do I'm gonna
put a minus sign at the front of my
absolute value are you with me see
what's going on there okay so this is
better it's got that dual asymptote
thing okay but then you've got um you
got a problem we've solved one problem
but we've created another one right
look closely with me is this what we
want it's not right
see how it's it's sharp right it's sharp
there and that's not good we have a name
for this kind of point it's called a
cusp see USP okay you're like I don't
want this okay I don't want it to be
sharp there I actually wanted to mean
look at the normal distribution I want
it to be we have a word for this starts
with S what's the we want it to
stationary not sharp okay now we
shouldn't be that surprised that trying
a trick like this makes it shot because
this is what the absolute value of or
negative the absolute value of X looks
like it's it's sharp right so what I
want is something that looks like this
but isn't sharp something that's concave
down sort of right but it's it's sort of
gentle right what do I want that would
do that and the answer is a shape that
you guys know right an upside down
parabola would do that right do you see
it's always negative that's what we
wanted and also it's it's gradual there
does that make sense so have a look at
what happens when we put this guy in the
index just take a look at that that's
pretty good right that's pretty good
okay now hold on we're not quite done
yet we're not quite done cuz look we
know just going back to the properties
of the normal distribution that the the
center right the symmetry of it should
be where figure out it's on it's on the
diagram right it should be centered
around the mean now this would be fine
if your mean was zero but like your
means not usually zero right it's some
other number okay what knowledge do we
have to be able to move this thing so it
centers somewhere else what would I do
sure okay there's gonna be a constant
where am I gonna put it
I've got to put it with the X right
because I want to move it left and right
does that make sense so this is what we
do you see how it's the same thing
you're looking at before but you've got
that minus mu in there which moves it
over does that make sense okay so you're
like aha now we're talking okay all
right now now stay with me etaf
we are almost there promise okay this
guy here is very close to the normal
distribution the only difference is we
don't know how fast spread out the thing
is or how tall it is okay
so just hold on to your hat and I am
gonna ask you to pick out your pins at
this point right in order to take this
guy which is basically the right
function and get the scale right we have
to add in stuff to do with the standard
deviation because that tells you how
stretched out this thing is okay so I
know it looks gross but compare it to
what we've got here okay this is the
real equation okay now it looks nasty
right can you write this down please
this is essential in fact I'm gonna
write it down to it now we're gonna
write this down together because I know
it looks like a goblin mess and so we're
gonna try and make it a little bit
better that's what we're gonna do right
now okay no this guy is not on the
formula shade I will I will tell you why
in a second but for now I want to work
with this function okay and the first
thing is let me just go back one slide
right you've got it if you haven't
written off the screen just right off
the whiteboard okay I can't go back as
I'm recording nevermind okay the
difference between this and what you
were just looking at in fact I'll write
down right the other the other function
we were looking at before looks like
this this is what we were looking at
right now just have a look at the
difference I know it looks it looks very
scary and intimidating right this this
guy comes into the denominator right and
then this guy comes out to the
coefficient okay
the key thing I want you to see is it's
to do with Sigma it's to do with how
spread out your data is okay now this
thing looks gross so I'm kind of on a
mission to simplify it and we can
because I want you to look closely at
the index
look at that garbled fraction up in
there right it's not a joke I wonder if
that thing in the index looks at all
familiar from what we've been looking at
this week
look a whole lot like the equation for
as its core right
the equation for the Zed score is it's X
minus mu all divided by Sigma right
which you've got all the pieces there so
here's what we're gonna do okay in your
book here's how we're gonna simplify
this thing okay this sky out the front
it just stays put it's fine but I want
to rewrite this index to make it a
little more obvious that I can see the
z-score in there okay for starters see
how there's a minus and then there's a
two on the bottom none of them appear in
the Zed score for me so I'm gonna pull
them out okay so I get this minus 1/2
and then you get left with X minus mu
squared on Sigma squared do you grow
that so I've broken the fraction into
two it looks gross but just have a look
at the second fraction yeah that's a
that's a multiplication yes okay have a
look at this second fraction do you
agree that basically I can take out this
squared thing right the top squared the
bottom squared so the whole thing is
squared does that make sense
but look this guy is that's that's the
z-score right there that's the z-score
okay now if you haven't written down up
to this point that's okay just put your
pens down for a second because I'm about
to do three things all at once and I
don't want you to miss them okay
I'm gonna highlight them all in colors
so you can see what's going on and I'm
gonna this is gonna be really weird I'm
gonna do it right to left because I
think that's gonna be the most sensible
order to do it in okay stay with me I've
got this e to the negative 1/2 and then
I've just said that this is Zed do you
agree that's that's the formula for the
z-score so the first thing that changes
is that turns into a Zed square said
okay then if you have a look in here
have a look at this fraction at the
front right 1 over now Sigma right
standard deviation have a look over at
my normal distribution on a z scale the
normal decide the standard deviation is
by definition just 1 right you see
that's the do
from one stand deviation to the next to
the next it's just one every time so
instead of writing one over Sigma this I
can just write 1 over 1 root 2 pi that
makes sense you see how I've substituted
that Sigma over there now the last thing
to do is see how we started by saying
this is a function of X this is not a
function of X anymore there are no more
X's what's this a function of it's a
function of Zed right so now I've got
all changes now you can pick your PIN
back up again right this is the line in
fact I'm gonna write it with um proper
colors and I don't need to write this
one doesn't change anything right our
probability density function we can
write as 1 over square root of 2 pi e to
the negative one onto Zed square
I know it's still not beautiful or
simple but it's better it's better than
what we started with okay and this
really will be the version that we use
going forward okay because it's it's
better than that guy all right now I
know this looks terrible okay but I want
to give you well this is the thing right
I here's my here's my arm here's my
pitch for you okay in two minutes or
less this is beautiful because it fits
every single thing that we wanted about
the normal distribution it's got the
symmetry it's got the right location
it's got the right size even though it
is complicated it does hey everything I
wanted to okay the only catch is when
you have a look at this guy right what
do we generally do with probability
density functions like how do I find a
probability how do I find variants how
what's the thing I do after this I
integrate right I integrate now if you
look at this and think gross I don't
want to integrate that then that's the
right instinct because I'm going to show
you what happens if you integrate the
probability density function what do we
call it when you integrate the PDF you
get the remember the CDF the cumulative
distribution function don't write this
down don't panic but this is the
cumulative distribution function okay
now I'm showing it to you because
thankfully for us we never ever need to
use this okay
you're wondering why there's an
exclamation like there it's a piece of
mathematical notation okay it's called
the factorial it's called a factorial
okay
now we're right on the bell so over the
next two days Thursday Friday what we're
gonna do is since we don't want to do
this what's the alternative there are
three alternatives and that's what we're
gonna do on Thursday and Friday